Alshe Run away Yes
, there is a possibility that you can escape if you fly
away.I will buy you 10 seconds, which takes a minute, so
that's a pretty interesting proposal.If you
go, you should abandon your friends
.
Abandon us, right? What
you should do 4
[Music] It
's okay, I'll defeat that monster called Ainz and chase you.
]
big cats
[music]
I thought I'd show Squad 3 on the road more secretly It's because it's
Nakano.
Tone, throwing away your life
Don't say this is easy 4
Was it Mark's Gospel?
There
is no lion to bet on you who are a tennu set
But let's
do the best for this girl Shall g Let's
teach that girl about
fear Raz grass and trees to lack when confronted with the fact from the holed room called Seikan  Let's start with
that, and then kill only
the days of pain.